newly obtained audio recording may be a
key piece of evidence in special counsel
Jack Smith's case that alleges former
president Trump put National Security at
risk by mishandling classified documents
including one he suggested was prepared
by joint Chief's chair General mark
milley
Pilots they present
to show off the Record but they
presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
according to the indictment the
recording from 2021 captured a
conversation Trump had at his New Jersey
golf club with a book writer a publisher
and two staffers none of whom are
believed to possess a security clearance
everywhere
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
there's a secret information